I think people are demonizing social
because it's showing us who we are in a
way that we aren't excited about I
believe that we are all going to become
way less hypocritical of each other once
we all realize we all have [ __ ] in our
closets
you got your perspective
[Applause]
dude and that's that can we go into the
other thing I want to ask you about
clouds and dirt as a philosophy massive
you know audacious perspective yeah and
deep practical capabilities yeah you
know double peas right if you can have
perspective proper macro perspective and
you can have micro you know practitioner
ship you will be happy and win yeah I
really believe that yeah having the
humility and the audacity back to your
contradiction but yeah I mean that's how
I got the clouds and dirt you know
because I've always been fascinated by
that about me which is the things I'm
willing to do right now that are below
my pay grade this podcast this is super
scrutinized by the people around me it's
like why are you doing this we don't
have 15 minutes for very important [ __ ]
you're letting money opportunity VIPs
why are you doing this I don't know like
intuitively when we were talking I
thought it was a good idea and I want to
I think you know in my massive personal
you know
perspective giving back I look you're
going to leverage me being on this show
for sure and that makes me feel good
that's me giving back this is a bigger
thing giving you these 15 minutes than
me giving you $15,000 for your app for
me it's easier to write the check so so
for me humility and like perspective
like I don't think I don't know how many
very busy people are running around
knowing that they need to put change
into the bucket of giving back in their
time not their money
about 70 years okay so now doing good I
believe that look look I'll be honest
with you I don't believe the current
school system is such a great proxy to
success and Happiness I really don't
know he could be doing that in school
for bad reasons but keep going so your
empathy okay so but how easy were you do
you know I mean it like how real are you
willing to get with yourself because you
mean you at 43 and 44 oh you know we
were meant for like 17 feels like
yesterday but your Monday through Friday
52 times hard to remember and the other
thing is you have the next cliche thing
that's gonna come out of your mouth is
your hard work has probably put him in a
place where he has the ability to have
more entitlement than you did yes and my
thing is you know I don't care if you
don't want to be I can't spare TV
Israeli so if you did that's cool but
can I tell you can I tell you yeah
listen can I tell you what I'm gonna do
so there's no better advice than eating
your own dog food behind our younger but
as long as you sit him down saying my
man and you've got to decide 18:22 you
can do it forever but if you say do you
but here's what's up when you turn 18
well when you turn 22 or whatever the
heck is gonna be in your house rules
you're out you're out not giving you a
dollar so I'm giving you back to your
game a year three years five or whatever
you're doing and like you want to leave
with 13 friends and you're gonna become
an NBA player a rapper or entrepreneur
or whatever Mazel Tov but I'm telling
you to your face out of love I'm not
giving you any money kids are lazy
because they think parents are gonna
take care of them and parents take care
of them because they don't want judgment
from others that their kids a loser be
I don't care if other parents think my
kids are losers I'm not gonna build a
fake environment for them because then
they'll never be achieving anything you
made a good video do you rock really I
like so you've been cold
[Music]
so heading now to dinner with the Vayner
productions team one of the things I'm
trying to always do is spend as much
time with my team as possible so a nice
little dinner with you know seven or ten
or fifteen of the leaders in production
which is a big growing part of our
business at Vayner I think yeah I think
it's helping so I understand what you're
you I do and I think everybody thinks
more like you I think what it's do
socially is not changing us it's
exposing us but it's also enhancing our
doorstep weirdness I don't think it's I
don't think it's I don't correct I think
it's I think the word exposing versus
enhancing is an important one
I think it's what people thought the
whole time what do you think was
happening Greenwich Connecticut in 1987
it was playing out in a country club in
the whispers in the darkness this is the
big I think people are demonizing social
because it's showing us who we are in a
way that we aren't excited about but all
those infidelities and behaviors and all
those other things were happening and by
showing it in the same way that I want
you to come and tell me not hide it it
gives us the ability to start addressing
it in a different way I believe that we
are all going to become way less
hypocritical of each other once we all
realize we all have [ __ ] in our closet
so I understand where you're coming from
and I promise you way more people agree
with you than me my take for the record
in perpetuity is it's the best thing
that's ever happened we will eat crow
for a generation but over time it will
lead us to a much better place I really
believe that look I think communication
solves everything
so what we're doing right now is we're
grappling with the communication tool of
today like hip hop
you've heard this for me I think cuz
you're a little close to my content it
will have you like I love them hip hop
like if you're said to me for your life
your life your life you have to get a
bunch of 14 to 18 year old white girls
in America to do something in six years
I literally start with Atlanta hip hop
artists
because I know that they are the
influencers of that behavior I've got to
make them do something build it and then
tweak it and then I can get every 15
year-old white girl in America to do
something by starting with lil baby and
gonna 29 months earlier
I think that's powerful and I think
certain people harness that it didn't
look if you even look at the way jay-z
navigates his life he understands it cuz
he's at the core like I love that it's
like who actually has the power I'll
tell you you want me to throw you for a
real rule I rarely say this Jason knows
this because he listens to everything I
say I don't like sharing this one cuz
it's too early I'm confident on my
hypothesis on this is good which is why
sharing I'm not as confident about what
I'm about to say but [ __ ] its building
and soon you might hear it from me
consistently for in a year I'm a weird
suspicion that the Internet and the
current state of America is
disproportionate to the have-nots that
the middle is being squeezed that the
internet doesn't give a [ __ ] who your
granddaddy was no granddaddy donates to
the [ __ ] library at Tulane and now
the kid goes to play on the Tulane
football team like [ __ ] goes down with
like like the minute like with the
leverage of money the internet just
[ __ ] place it's why sunny cloud
rappers are the biggest rappers that
emerge nobody's in charge there's no
hard drive anymore that's like you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]